notamment pour vous madame vigneault
henry vous demande pourquoi vous refusez
le déploiement de la 5g à besançon le
déploiement la 5g à besançon aujourd'hui
il est remis en cause non pas dans dans
le fait de déployer il est remis en
cause dans le fait qu'on ne connaît pas
encore les risques que l'on pourrait
encourir à nous avons aujourd'hui le
gouvernement lançait un sénateur des
républicains qui dit nous n'avons pas
suffisamment d'information fasozine
technologiques pourraient exposer
l'ensemble de la population
il est urgent de faire des études qui en
mesurent les effets donc je tiendrai un
principe de précaution parce qu'il est
on avance très souvent sur la
technologie sans savoir ce que l'on fait
stéphane vous dis madame vigneault par
excès de prudence envers le progrès ne
risque-t-on pas de voir les entreprises
s'implantèrent ailleurs le progrès il ne
l on a démontré avec le co vide que le
progrès un moment donné nous a amené à
arrêter toute l'économie
je tiens quand même à ce qu'on se
rappelle de ce qui vient de nous arriver
à force de dérivés en matière d'écologie
on a vu se développer une crise majeure
qui a été une crise sanitaire et cette
crise sanitaire nous a amené à une crise
économique
on a tout arrêter du jour au lendemain
on va continuer à avoir des dérives de
ce type là qui permette qui disent le
libéralisme nous permet tout et on
réfléchit après on veut réfléchir avant
on veut faire des études avant et savoir
pourquoi on déploie ses technologies le
4g on peut déjà faire beaucoup de choses
eric alauzet frais prendrez-vous un
moratoire sur le déploiement de 5 g si
vous êtes maire dimanche avec le vrai
problème c'est qu'on n'a pas la 4g
partout donc on apprenne d'équité des
territoires y compris dans
l'agglomération je ne parle même pas des
territoires ruraux
donc on a une responsabilité collective
à ce que l'ensemble du territoire avance
en même temps donc déjà mettons de la 4g
partout métaux de la fibre partout et
puis un débat il ya une controverse ça
fait partie des sujets y compris au
gouvernement
faut il accepter des controverses on l'a
vu dans le coma comment les
scientifiques ont visité donc fondre à
ma question je prépare ou pas à votre
question parce qu'il faut continuer pour
des expérimentations voulait attendre
les quotas
le rapport de l'homme cesse leurs amis
les rapports mais vous savez même le
rapport de l'an 100 e tranche sera
peut-être pas le jeu je connais beaucoup
de sujets comme ça qui traîne depuis des
années et qui ne sont pas tranchés voilà
donc prudents mais 4g partout fibre par
tous les jeudis de vic fagots le
principe de précaution vous le voyez
vous le balayer d'un revers de main et
inévitablement parce qu'aujourd'hui si
vous voulez l'arcep qui est quand même
le régulateur des télécoms a démontré
qu'il n'y avait pas donc défait par
rapport à ça vous avez vous évoqué des
éléments excusez moi mais c'est pas mon
régulateur des télécoms et de faire des
études sur les conséquences et la mise à
la jambe
vous avez l'âge entre les fréquences
aussi qu'il ya eu plusieurs organistes
l'agent des fréquences la mfr il a quand
même évoqué par rapport à cela
moi aujourd'hui si vous voulez les
décroissants et madame vigneault qui
dans cette décroissance
ils veulent vraiment libéré il dit il
veut vraiment limite les limites et les
libertés des uns et des autres nous on
est pour l'innovation
on est pour le progrès et aujourd'hui
oui vous avez raison monsieur alauzet il
faut déployer déployer davantage la
fibre avec des problèmes quand même
technique d'infrastructures au
centre-ville mais aussi il fournit des
réponses orthez sur la 4g et la saint
jean